um what I thought was dope was when you
jumped on uh Russ's Chomp project was it
Chomp two euron Trump yeah was it the
second one chop one or two which one was
it was it 20 21 or 2020. anyway well
you're on one of the Chomps yeah
um and I know Russ has always been like
a huge uh fan of yours anytime I've ever
talked to him he's always brought you up
it's like you know it's my brother the
young Legend man yeah and like it's
funny because like he had shared uh some
old DMS where he was hitting you up yeah
like 2011. yeah like he used to like
harass me on Twitter yeah that was so
cool and now you jumped on his [ __ ] and
then now he's on your [ __ ] like yeah
talk about your relationship with a guy
like Russ who I think is
given a lot of free games a lot of
artists out there yeah it doesn't he
doesn't just keep the game behind the
lock locked doors right right I think
some people might take his messaging the
wrong way I think he's a great guy you
know I I know I know he means well I
mean he you know he that's what he just
he's just uh
he's just a free spirit for sure at
heart and he just he just means well I
mean he's he's just trying to be of
service
um but
I just I I think he's just like the
definition of
dedication yeah is the definition of
dedication and consistency and
you know he's he's really you know he's
very he's very skilled he's very
intuitive
you know what I'm saying like I you know
and he could rap his ass off nah that's
what I'm saying like he's he's really
skilled so you know and that's like I
said man that's that's
the young Legend and like as somebody
like you grew up when he read when he
reached out to me I had like I had kept
hearing his name right
and I had and I had heard his records
but I didn't you know put a face to it
or you know
but you know uh he reached out to punch
and punch sent me the record and then I
was like oh oh this is cool like would
you like should I do it he was like oh
yeah I I love his Hustle
so I'm like all right yeah cool so he
gave me his number and then I reached
out to him and then we had to talk and
then he sent me like the old tweets yo
this is crazy so then I did my research
I'm like oh this is this guy um oh wow
yeah oh oh for sure so you know yeah
shout outs around